[音楽]
moon
むーん
みなさんが普段利用している電車やバスタクシー
そういった公共交通知らんが足りない地域があるのをご存知でしょうか
ここに一定の手紙があります
この手紙はある島ノ江通過ライン悩む
そんな方からいただいたすごく熱のこもったお手紙でした
この島は毎年4万人もの観光客が訪れます
一方でねー
公共交通手段は3台のタクシーと
一つの路線のバスたたそれしかありません
今までこの島では
地元の方々がこの島をどうにかしていきたいとそういう思いで無料の送迎を行うことで
何買ってきました
しかしそれも流石に限界があるということでその現状をなんとかできないか
そういったことが書かれたお手紙でした
の手紙が僕の元に届いたのは
2015年からクルーという
自家用車を有効活用していくのもブリッジのプラットフォームも僕が運営していたから
でした
くれは
自家用車で人を運ぶ人々と移動したい人をマッチングするそんなプラットフォームです
自家用車で移動手伝ってくれたドライバーさんのおもてなしに対してありがとうの
気持ちで
されを者らうことができるそんなスキームのサービスになっています
僕の当初の思いは日本ならではの
そういう昔からあれ
工場とかいてお互いに助けるようなサービスをテクノロジーでいかに日本に拡張して
いくか
そんなことを考えてつけたサービスでしたが
このサービスの立ち上げは簡単なものではありませんでした
そこに立ちはだかったのは規制の壁です
あらゆる産業には
市民の生活を保護するために様々なルールがされています
その中で
急成長してきた沢山のスタートアップがこの規制との向き合い方を
苦しんできました
それは仮想通貨もそうですし
キレーションメジャーもそうですし
シェアリングエコノミーのサービスがアップしそうです
このクルーというサービスを立ち上げて世に広めていく上で
僕はこうしたイノベーターと規制を司る
ルールメーカー
ここの関係線に新しいデザインが必要だと考えそれを3つのステップで定義しました
その一つ目が
すべてを社会から怒ら話し始めるとそういうことです
正直僕よりも規制だとか
法律だとかそういったことに詳しい方々は世の中にゴマンといらっしゃると思ってい
ます
その中で
僕がすごく規制が難しいとされる自家用車の領域で
サービスを立ち上げてくることができたのはこうした社会課題と真摯に今までずっと
向き合ってきたからだと思います
こうした社会課題というのは時代とともに移り変わるもので
かこつけたレールが今の社会課題に対して適用が難しくなってくるとこの今に今の時代
にふさわしいルールを新しく作る必要が出てくる
そうしたときに初めてイノベーターとルールメーカーが同じ目線で何かを作り上げる
ことができると思っています
お恥ずかしい話僕も
そんなほどいいな手紙をいただくまでは日本のローカルの交通課題がどれほど深刻化と
いうのはあまり分かっていませんでした
ただ
こうした手紙とに生の声を頂いてしかもそれを上をしていく中の何年間も全国各地から
頂く中で
こうした社会課題があるんだなと
僕がぐるっというサービスを作ってきたのは彼らのような方々や
をマジような境遇で苦しむ方々にこのサービスを届けるためなんだなと改めてしみじみ
と感じました
鹿児島県のヨロン島という島で昨年の夏から実証実験を行っております
この島はご覧の通りすごく海が綺麗な島でこの観光資源に恵まれている中毎年7万人の
観光客が訪れます
結構インスタ倍もするので毎年1万人ずつ缶紅茶が増えていたりするんですけれども
その中でパッたタクシーが8台しかいないんですね
僕がこのプレーのサービスをやり始める前に訪れた時も街の中を
炎天下で歩いていると
君大丈夫です島民の方々が心配し乗せてってくれるようなそういう心の温かい島です
だからこそこの校長交通知らんが足りない中でもこの島ではそういった移送したい道を
なんとか2本までが進めてきたんですけれどもそれが今後より難しくなってきていると
いうのがこの島の現状です
僕は公有地化で自分の足で見て声を聞いてこの課題感を実感し
こうした課題をルールメーカーと一緒に取り組んでいく必要があると考えました
このようにすべての話のはじめを社会から犬を持っていくということは今までの
イノベーターはできていなかったことなのかもしれないと思っています
それは
サービスをするときはやはりこういうユーザーとも行っちゃうことが大事になって
しまって社会というものまで考えていくとというのが
実際僕もサービスを始めた時はすごく難しかったですしよくあることだと思うんです
けれども
ルールメーカーとイノベーターの新しい関係性の第一のステップとして全てを社会課題
からスタートするということを提言したいと思います
社会課題を明確化し
その次の第2のステップとして僕がるーメーカーとイノベーターの関係性に関して提案
するのは社会課題を可視化することです
みなさんも普段社会科5向き合おうと
強く思っていたとしても日々の生活の中で社会課題を認知していくということはすごく
難しいことだなと思います
でも実際に社会課題を解決して木に当たっては
その辛いをもっとたくさんの人を巻き込んでしって言ってもらう必要があります
今までこのように社会課題を可視化していくということは
ルールメーカーの方々が実際に粒度をつくって木に当たって必要だと考えてやってきた
ことでした
ただイノベーションが起こるような社会課題が高時代によって移り変わっていく速度が
速い
そんな領域では
イノベーターの方が実際の社会課題の生の声だったりとか
この手紙もそうですけれども生のデータであったりとか
4時より新しく最新の課題というものを理解できているというそういう現状もあると
思います
ちょうど今年からクレーは都市部での交通課題のリサーチを始めました
それは
満員電車ってこうもっとどうにかすることができないのかなとか
雨の日や雪の日に
公共交通機関が麻痺してしまっていてその中でどれぐらい困ってる人がいるんだろう
それに対してもっと出来ることってないのかなと
その上で
僕らはこうした生の声やデータを自分たちだけでは泣けるーでメーカーの方々と許攸し
ながら社会課題と向き合っていくことがこれからの時代に必要なことだと思っています
イノベータとれるメーカーが社会課題の可視化に取り組んでいく
これがば次の新しい時代での
れるメーカーとイノベーターの関係性だと僕は思います
実際に社会課題を明確化しそれを可視化し
最後には
その社会からに対して取り組んでいく
イノベーションを社外に実装していくとして取られます
茹でるメーカーとイノベーターの新しい関係性
その場合さんのステップで必要とされるのはプランゼットの構築です
イノベたというのは
リスクテイカーの集まりだと僕は思っています
それは彼らが今まで誰も実現したことがなかった
難しい挑戦をしているからです
しかし実際に色べーションをその社会に実装して木に当たっては
こうしたリスクを提供していく
プラン a plan b のもしこれがうまくいったらというそういう発想のプラン
ではなくて
本当にワーストのリスクシナリオであるすべてのケースが最悪だった場合のプラン
ゼットというものをこう月していく必要があります
僕がこの考えに至ったきっかけは
初めて館長にお伺いした時でした
僕は干潮にプレーのサービスのリーガルのスキーについて説明をしに来ました
こういうスキームで現在行っていて鉄橋だと思っています
そういう説明を弁護士の先生としに行ったんですけど
実際にその担当者の方に言われたのはまったく別のアプローチでした
これってつまりは他人の車に一緒に乗るということだよねー
もし何かがトラブルが起きたら君たちはどうするの
このままサービスが拡大していくとそれはもう確率論として仕方ないことだけれども
いつかは交通事故が起こるでしょう
それに対して君たちはどのように向き合っていいのかと
相当荒れました
正直
言われなくても頭の中ではいつかは交通事故が起こるものだしそれに対して取り組んで
いきしてはあるとそれはサービスをやり始めた時から思っていたことでしたが
実際にサービスの運用していると
そうしたプランテッドの構築本当のワーストケースに対しての対策っていうのが
どんどん後回しになってしまう
そんな実情があると思います
ただ
イノベーションを起こしていく社会的な大きなインパクトをしていこうとすると
それだけ大きな社会的社会的な責任が生じて
その責任に対してのこのプランゼットというところが強く求められるのが
今のルールメーカーからもそうですし実際に世の中の人々からのにいつも最後はそう
いうところだと思います
ちょうど
今年の1月
グレーは1カ月間のサービスのメンテナンスでサービスを軽視しました
その間で安心安全対策の徹底を行った
こうなったんですけど
そういう日々のサービスの成長を求められるようなスタートアップで1ヶ月間サービス
の中止をするっていうのは極めて異例なことだと僕は思います
それでも
そうしたプラン鉄塔と向き合っていくその姿勢がこれからの時代においての
イノベーターの姿勢として極めて求められるものであるし
それ自体がすごく本質的に社会から求められていることだと感じたのでそのような決断
をしました
今後の
ルールメーカーとイノベーターの新しい関係性
その中ではこうしたプランゼットどこまで高月できるか
そうした問いと向き合っていく必要があると思います
世の中には
本当に様々なところに身近なところも含めて社会課題が転がっています
僕はその一つ一つの社会課題とその社会課題と向き合っている人々と実際に対話し真剣
になっていくとそういう姿勢が
イノベーターだとかれるメーカーだとかそうした立場と関係なくすべての人々に求め
られていく
そんな姿勢だと思います
何か新しいものを作る際に
こういうはとらしいものがあったら夜中ってどんなどれだけを受けられるだろうと
そういう提案が
いろんな場所になされていると思いますが
これからの時代はこの新しいものが
そうしてされなくなることで
世の中の社会課題のどういったものが取り残されてしまうのか
そう言うという思って
ルーでメーカーとイノベーターが向き合うことができれば
今よりももっとより良い社会が実現されていくと
僕はそう信じています
僕も
一人の当事者として
交通課題という社会課題と向き合っていきます
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]